in the tropical heat of a madagascan
afternoon
the shade of the trees
is a welcome relief
the going is tough through a dense
jungle of mango wild banana and palm
and the expedition makes slow progress
trailing machete wielding guides
the year is 1860
and these remote forests have never
before been seen by western eyes
and what wonders there are
[Music]
plants trees and animals completely
unknown in africa just a few hundred
kilometers to the west let alone the
rest of the world
bloated baobabs delicate orchids
and above all else
lemus
[Music]
as the exhausted party rest within the
sweltering understory a family of these
curious animals clatters noisily through
the canopy overhead
shrieking their alarm at the intruders
below
dense foliage hides the mammals from
view but a rare glimpse shows a long
black and white striped tail swung out
for balance
below one of the westerns wipes sweat
from his brow as he hastily notes down
the sighting
another novel variety to add to his
ever-growing list
by the end of that year that
wonderstruck adventurer had survived the
voyage back to england
presenting his sweat stained notebook
along with several crates of samples to
the secretary at the zoological society
philip slater
[Music]
slater had made a name for himself in
the realms of ornithology proposing a
new way to divide the globe
based on the distributions of birds
but as with many of his fellow scholars
of the victorian age his curiosity about
the natural world could not be contained
and now he turned his attentions to the
mammals of madagascar
[Music]
he poured over the specimens returned to
him probing and classifying with intense
fervor
and slowly
and surely a seed of an idea grew inside
his mind
[Music]
there was indeed a staggering bounty of
lemur species in madagascar
ring-tailed lemurs like the one glimpsed
through the trees were joined by 29
other distinct types
such variety for such an isolated island
in comparison africa boasted a mere 12
species
and the indian subcontinent only three
the implication could not have been
clearer in slater's mind
madagascar had to be the primordial
homeland of these tree-dwelling mammals
from which the asian and african
varieties were derived
but how had they crossed the great
oceans between
[Music]
slater was once again confident in his
conclusion
they must have traveled over land
[Music]
across a land bridge that had once
connected asia madagascar and africa
such a bridge must have been gigantic in
extent occupying much of the western
indian ocean
in fact it would be more fitting to call
it
a continent
slater named this hypothetical lost
continent the supposed connection that
allowed lemurs to flow out of their
homeland
the muria
[Music]
at this point of the 19th century the
idea of lost continents was not such an
outrageous one
as geologists strove to understand the
rocks that painted the globe they
imagined ocean basins as sunken drowned
land masses
our continents today may have been
raised dripping from the seabed
producing marine fossils in unlikely
inland locations
so slater's proposition of the sunken
continent of lemuria was a sensible
scientific supposition
but the following decades would see his
ideas seized and transported outside the
realms of science
and ultimately into the occult
[Music]
in 1876 a new rejection of the theory of
evolution was published by german
zoologist ernst heckel
his history of creation not only
rejected darwin's suggestion that humans
had evolved and radiated from africa
preferring an asian origin instead but
suggested it was lemuria that the lost
cradle of humanity could be found
for heckle it was here among the limas
and the other lower primates that
mankind first emerged spreading to asia
and africa before the continent sank
[Music]
in later translations of heckle's work
maps depicting the muria in the indian
ocean were labeled paradise
[Music]
in the decades that followed the idea
was transformed yet further
for the russian medium helena blavatsky
whose esoteric religious doctrine
theosophy was followed by 45 000 at its
peak including members of high society
the muria was the mythical homeland of
one of the seven races of humanity
a group of egg-laying hermaphrodites
endowed with four arms and four eyes
who lived alongside dinosaurs on the
lost continent until its fiery
destructive end
the concept of lemuria from its
well-intentioned scientific beginnings
to its strange transcendence into the
occult
was one that nevertheless persisted well
into the 20th century
it wasn't until modern theories of plate
tectonics came to the fore that the lost
continent was finally sunk
and so the last 60 years of geological
and geophysical study have revealed an
altogether more provable history of
continental movements through time
rather than merely rising or sinking
they traverse the globe
joining and splitting building and
shattering
lemuria may never have existed but we
now glimpse an even more evocative past
there are generations of earth's
long-lost supercontinents waiting to be
discovered
[Music]
[Music]
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
magellan have been great supporters of
the channel for a while now they offer a
vast range of programmes on a truly
comprehensive range of topics more than
3 000 in total
from the depths of space to the
dinosaurs there's something here for
everyone head over to history of the
universe to find out how they've
inspired our work
and one magellan dock that we enjoyed
recently that pairs nicely with this
video on supercontinents is super
volcanoes a fascinating exploration of
what makes these earth-shaping titans
tick
and you can now take advantage of an
exclusive offer 30 off an annual
membership this gives you an entire year
for less than 3.50 a month
even if you've joined magellan before
and lapsed you can simply click on the
link in the description to claim your
discounted membership today
[Music]
towards the end of 1994 a small
spacecraft plunged whirling into the
scorching clouds of venus
it was a graceful death well deserved by
a probe that had accomplished so much in
its short life
for the last four years the magellan
probe had been swooping past the
shrouded planet in great polar loops
passing from north to south just 300
kilometers above the surface
before swinging far out back into space
to prepare for another pass
[Music]
with each transit as the planet rotated
serenely beneath its clouds
magellan imaged a new swathe of the
venetian surface
but normal cameras would not suffice
here
earth's twisted neighbor is so
thoroughly wrapped in cloud and haze
that visible light cannot hope to
penetrate
instead magellan scanned the alien
surface with radar and in less than two
years had mapped 98 percent of the
surface in unprecedented detail
but the radar images revealed something
strange
venus seemed to have no continents at
all
despite being so similar to earth in
size and rocky composition the swaddled
planet seemed to have none of our
surface diversity
magellan saw plenty of volcanic features
from shield volcanoes to vast lava
fields but they were all hallmarks of a
single basaltic rock
no sedimentary deltas no metamorphic
mountains no explosive stratovolcanoes
only dark
fluid lava over the planet's entire
surface
magellan's data was invaluable to
scientists trying to understand how
venus became earth's evil twin
the radar images revealed that the plate
tectonics that defied our surface never
really played a role on venus
without the lateral movement and
recycling of the crust there was nothing
driving the creation of new types of
rock
without a tectonically driven rock cycle
and being positioned that much closer to
the sun than earth
venus's conditions spiraled out of
control
without plate tectonics the planet
was baked alive
[Music]
earth was dealt a luckier hand
the beginning of plate tectonics
established a feedback cycle
that has protected us from venus's fate
for the last three and a half billion
years
those plate tectonics have also endowed
our planet with a startling variety of
rock types
and we can trace the first continents of
all
to those earliest creeping moments
continental crust is special it has a
distinct and refined composition
like a fine whiskey to the raw grain
mash of the oceanic crust
[Music]
as plates collide they crumple and
thicken allowing molten rocks to sit for
longer in the heart of the crust
[Music]
here they partially crystallize
losing their heavier minerals and
becoming progressively lighter and less
dense
[Music]
it is these relatively lightweight
granitic rocks that are the foundation
of our continents
and they have been gradually
accumulating ever since plate tectonics
began
because of their lower density they
float buoyantly on the top of the mantle
and are not easily subducted at
collisional plate boundaries
instead it is the denser basaltic
oceanic crust that floats lower and is
sacrificed at subduction zones
in this way continents once formed stand
proud bubbling like a cork that won't be
sunk
they can be destroyed of course by the
forces of wind water and ice but in any
clash of tectonic sumo these bulky
behemoths will always emerge victorious
the oldest remaining fragments of
continental crust today are some three
and a half billion years old
they have persisted in the face of
erosion collision and rifting
we know their great age from mineral
crystals called zircons that are some of
the most resilient constituents of
continental rocks and which contain a
precise elemental clock in the form of
decaying uranium atoms
by precisely measuring the proportions
of original uranium and its decay
product lead geologists can reconstruct
the age of the crystal and therefore the
rock that contains it
even after the original rock is eroded
away the zircons will survive
to be reincorporated into sedimentary
rocks and preserve an echo of the
mountain that gave them birth
in this way tens of thousands of zircons
have been dated to build a picture of
continental crust creation through
geological time
more zircons imply more rock formation
but the actual record seems to show a
surprising pattern
there are times when zircon production
is inexplicably low
when continents
merely exist and are barely being added
to at all
how does this fit with a global picture
of plate tectonics
to understand that we must take a step
back from individual crystals
and search for other clues in the
continental fragments preserved on earth
today
[Music]
in the 16th century perhaps no one in
the world had looked at earth's
continents quite as closely as abraham
ortelius
[Music]
fascinated by the intricate process and
artistry of committing vast swathes of
land to a single sheet of paper he
pursued cartography with almost every
waking moment
it is little wonder then that this
influential geographer saw something in
the shape of the world that none had
given voice to before
the coasts of europe africa and the
americas
seem to match one another
ortelius imagined these continents
ripped apart as he described it by
devastating earthquakes and floods
arguably he was the first to imagine the
concept of continental drift
an idea which wouldn't truly be
popularized until the early 20th century
by the meteorologist alfred wegner
for it would be nearly 400 years before
modern scientists could verify that the
dutchman's suppositions were in fact
correct
africa europe and the americas had
indeed once been joined and had been
torn apart by the inexorable forces of
plate tectonics
earthquake and flood was just the
beginning of the catastrophe that befell
these once united continents
[Music]
as ortelius contemplated the shapes of
shorelines on his 53-page atlas of 1565
he was unknowingly tracing the open
wound of a supercontinent
ripped asunder
there are no supercontinents on earth
today the largest discrete landmass is
eurasia with an area of around 55
million square kilometers
but even this gigantic continent makes
up little more than a third of all the
land area on earth
various definitions of supercontinents
require that all or nearly all of the
earth's continental crust be gathered
into a single immense and unbroken
landmass
[Music]
[Applause]
alternatively some scientists accept a
more loose definition that the
supercontinent is merely the joining of
continents that had previously been
separated
yet still whichever way we look at it
there are no supercontinents on earth
today
but there are clues buried within the
crust that show that this hasn't always
been the case
[Music]
the young crust of ocean basins
preserves one of the clearest histories
of continental movement through time
oceanic crust is produced at mid-ocean
ridges
like the one in the center of the
atlantic
adding incrementally to the gigantic
slabs either side at a pace of two and a
half centimeters per year
that's roughly the same speed as our
fingernails grow
[Music]
the great continents attached to these
slabs are shifted by the same amount
so by reversing this oceanic conveyor we
can travel back through time
[Music]
and close the atlantic
reuniting europe and africa with the
americas
other ocean basins aren't always so easy
to interpret but geologists turn to the
fossil compasses frozen in these rocks
to reconstruct the time and direction of
movement
as our magnetic field has periodically
flip-flopped swapping north and south
magnetic poles every few million years
the reversals are recorded in the new
crust that forms
stripes of magnetic anomalies are etched
invisibly into the crust
like data on an old videotape
once again we can play that tape
and watch the continents
dance
but ocean basins can only help us so far
unlike continental crust oceanic slabs
are easily sacrificed to the mantle when
two plates clash
and the constant production in one place
on the globe inevitably means constant
destruction elsewhere
the oldest ocean crust that survives
today is just 340 million years old in
the mediterranean sea
that means there is still some 3 billion
years of continental movement that we
cannot hope to know from basins alone
for that geologists must turn to the
continents themselves
the land masses preserve a history of
where the rocks have traveled as well as
the trials they have faced
through the years
the volcanic rocks that preserve fossil
compasses are rare on the continents and
not regular enough to preserve the
periodic reversals but they can still be
used to pinpoint the magnetic pole at
the time of rock formation
if that rock has since rotated or moved
east or west then its fossil compass
will be misaligned
moving the rock and its associated land
mass back we can plot that continent's
position at the moment the rock formed
and more traditional fossils offer a
straightforward reconstruction of
continental juxtaposition
if fossils of the same organism are
found on now separated continents we can
assume that these landmasses were once
connected somehow
[Music]
by plotting the paleogeography of entire
fossil communities paleontologists can
reconstruct not only the ancient
continental configurations but also the
locations of these landmasses on the
earth
300 million year old fossils of
gosopterus a tall woody shrub with
tongue-shaped leaves are found in
antarctica india australia south africa
and south america
[Music]
their distribution suggests that not
only were these now disparate land
masses once united but that the
resulting supercontinent must have sat
at temperate or tropical latitudes
where the wet swampy conditions the
plant preferred could dominate
the distribution of lima like animals
across africa madagascar and india today
is not due to the sunken land bridge of
their muria
but rather a sign that the three were
once joined
and have since been rent apart by
lateral plate tectonics
[Music]
other clues in the surviving continents
are harder to decode but offer a window
into the moments of continental
collision and separation
when two buoyant land masses collide and
neither is willing to succumb to
subduction the rocks crack crumple
compress and eventually come to rest
[Music]
the resulting mountain chains can reach
many miles higher than surrounding
landscape like the himalayan range and
tibetan plateau today
and the rocks formed at their hearts
preserve the tortured scars of the
collision that formed them
[Music]
and over millions of years
even the tallest mountain eventually
succumbs to erosion
and the hearts of these ancient ranges
are exposed at the surface
they are known as orogenic belts
using these warped rocks to reconstruct
mountain building events many hundreds
of millions of years in the past is not
straightforward
but doing so reveals precisely which
continental slabs collided and when
yet even if we don't fully know why
we now have a clearer picture than ever
of our planet's checkered
supercontinental past
[Music]
scotland and england are now as one
fused together at the northern edge of
the eurasian continent
but this was not always the case
[Music]
500 million years ago they were
separated by a great ocean the iapetus
[Music]
the plate tectonics is of a fickle and
driven by the unpredictable flows of the
upper mantle gradually the iapetus ocean
basin began to close
the continent of laurentia along with
the scottish homeland bore down upon
baltica and what was to become england
when all of the ocean basin was gone the
two leviathan continents crashed into
one another
building mountains in an event known as
the caledonian orogeny
and fusing the laurentian and balticon
continents together forever
by 420 million years ago in the silurian
period when life had barely made it onto
the land the iapetus ocean was no more
and all that remained was the twisted
crash site of two continents forced
unforgivingly together
that crumpled mountain range has since
eroded
[Music]
but geologists can still trace the
tortured scars across the british
landscape
[Music]
the iapetus suture zone runs from the
solway firth to lindisfarne
uncannily close to the modern scottish
border
the iapetus suture is just one of the
scars left behind in ancient continental
crust
there are collision zones like it all
over the world
but as we probe further back in time
crustal clues that have escaped erosion
become increasingly hard to find
some of the oldest remnants of
continents called cratons can be found
in canada australia
south africa and elsewhere today
but there are tantalizing hints that in
their earliest days they were united
into one or a series of archaean
supercontinents
[Music]
one reconstruction extends the record of
supercontinents almost back to the first
continental masses of all
a single early continent
has been proposed based on the
observation that all of the cratons
dating to 3 billion years ago were
clustered together at a later time so
are likely to have formed and stayed
together since their earliest moments
but with such ancient rocks few other
clues remained that could hint at the
configuration or position of er and its
very existence relies on a great number
of assumptions
instead a more conservative reassembly
suggests that the ancient cratons were
incorporated into a series of continents
that formed and reformed throughout the
archaean and into the early proterozoic
the first was valbara
which reigned from around 3.4 to 2.7
billion years ago
and combined the cup val craton now
found in south africa and the pilbara
creighton of australia
next came the continent known as
superior which existed from 2.7 to 2.3
billion years ago
and of which only the canadian superior
craton survives today
[Music]
at the same time the slavia continent
including the modern canadian slave
craton reigned from 2.6 to roughly 2
billion years ago
these reconstructions are based on the
scant ancient evidence available from
these and other crustal blocks
including the pulses in zircon creation
that are consistent with their assembly
but we have no real way of knowing where
they existed on the surface of the earth
some have even suggested that they were
all united as far separated parts of a
single long-lived supercontinent called
keno land
whose central regions have since been
lost to time
[Music]
[Applause]
if we could speed the geological clock
from the early protozoa today we will be
able to see the continental dance for
what it really is
individual land masses grow slightly but
mostly they pivot
slide and link along oceanic distances
sometimes the dancers are spread far
apart and sometimes they linger locked
in and embrace
those close holds represent the fleeting
tenures of supercontinents and the dance
is punctuated by their calm motions
before the continents whirl away once
more
the supercontinent known as colombia
assembled around 1.8 billion years ago
from crustal blocks that would later
form parts of north america greenland
and europe
it was nearly 13 000 kilometers north to
south and likely straddled the equator
favoring the northern hemisphere
different interpretations of the
original belts left behind from that
time produce very different
reconstructions of these continental
fragments
[Music]
one suggests that pieces of antarctica
and australia lay along the north
american west coast
while an alternative places india in the
same position
geological evidence suggests that the
colombian supercontinent persisted until
around a billion years ago
possibly contributing to a period of
unprecedented environmental stability
known affectionately as the boring
billion
at the end of its tenure new rifts
formed and new continents tore away
next came rodinia proposed timings for
rodinia assembly actually overlap with
the breakup of colombia
so it is possible that continents
fleeing one super assembly were soon
caught in the grip of another
but as for colombia before it
reconstructions are notable for their
lack of agreement
at this significantly younger age there
are many more rocks available for
comparison but they are still disparate
and much altered by time
most geologists agree that the north
american crustal block known as
laurentia formed the core of rodinia
with eastern europe amazonia and west
africa to the southeast
and australia india and antarctica to
the north east
fragments of crust that now form the
eastern part of brazil were attached to
the south
[Music]
but the positions of ancient portions of
china and siberia are still the subject
of debate
to further complicate matters as well as
overlapping with colombia's breakup
rodinia assembly may have been
concurrent with its own destruction
like some vast and ponderous newton's
cradle continents crashed into the scrum
even as others broke free
the proterozoic earth's surface was
cluttered with cratons as rodinia broke
up between 850 and 600 million years ago
some passed briefly across the south
pole colliding as they approached from
different directions as rodinia turned
itself inside out across the globe
the resulting supercontinent pannosia
saw the congo craton amalgamated with
laurentia and other rodinian fragments
but the union was not to last
even as the final sutures were healed
around the edges penosha began to rift
apart from the middle as a new ocean
basin the iapetus appeared and began to
widen
the very existence of penosha is far
from certain
as the messi breakup of rodinia is
difficult to reconstruct across the
precambrian cambrian boundary
[Music]
but the next or possibly concurrent
continental amalgamation is much better
constrained
gondwana may only be considered a
supercontinent under one of the terms
looser definitions as several ancient
cratons were excluded from its embrace
[Music]
and yet this land mass which began its
assembly with the chaotic destruction of
rodinia and was only completed at the
very end of the protozoa did represent
the largest single piece of continental
crust throughout the paleozoic
covering an area of around 100 million
square kilometers it saw two-thirds of
today's continental area united
including cratons from modern-day india
africa south america antarctica
australia and arabia
[Music]
this supercontinent was a melting pot of
ancient landmasses
and was crisscrossed by orogenic belts
each marking a collision a lost ocean
a continental fusion
[Music]
the origin of gondwana was a brief calm
moment after the continental chaos of
the late proterozoic
for a few hundred million years there
were no more collisions and the
supercontinent drifted gently northwards
until it eventually met its end
335 million years ago
unlike those that came before it
gondwana did not die through shattering
rifts and diverging fragments
rather it lost its supercontinental
identity as it collided with the now
combined laurentia and baltica
it was assimilated into a greater whole
a supercontinent in even the strictest
sense
the last supercontinent
pangaea
where there was naught but disagreement
about the configurations of previous
supercontinents
in pangaea there is a wealth of
supporting and corroborating evidence
there are plenty of rocks from its
mesozoic tenure
including fossils that can be mapped
across once and future fragments
consistent magnetic anomalies and
unaltered orogenic belts
pangaea with its gondwan and southern
regions reigned until 180 million years
ago
[Music]
the breakup of this vast and resplendent
supercontinent saw the opening of the
atlantic ocean the migration of india
towards the asian subcontinent and the
utter isolation of australia and
antarctica
and so
we find our modern world
formed from the scattered fragments of
pangaea
but also of gondwana
panosia rodinia colombia and maybe even
kennel land and er
[Music]
each supercontinental age was distinct
in configuration duration climate and
character
pangaea was covered in great forests
while rodinia was barely greened at the
edges
panosha was a frozen wasteland while
colombia baked in endless deserts
yet despite their differences there are
certain conditions that all of these
supercontinents shared
and which life may face
in the coming supercontinental age
[Music]
alexander von humboldt was driven by an
insatiable curiosity for the world
around him
the german scholar traveled extensively
through the americas and russia
seeking to learn the secrets of those
often harsh but exotic lands
[Music]
wherever he traveled he erected weather
stations to measure the air temperature
pressure and rainfall
and he collected data whenever he could
to build a picture of weather variations
over time and space
[Music]
by 1830 he had collected enough data to
map out those conditions over a huge
swathe of western europe and russia
[Music]
von humboldt was the first to see
clearly in his data what any siberian
nomad could have told him
the further inland you travel the more
extreme the weather would become
winters in the interior were colder and
summers were hotter than in coastal
places at the same latitude
[Music]
this so-called continentality is a
feature of all large land masses on
earth today
and is more pronounced the larger the
continent
for instance antwerp close to the north
sea in northern belgium experiences an
average summer to winter temperature
range of nearly 15 degrees celsius
meanwhile saratov deep in central russia
sits at the same latitude but is some
2000 kilometers from the nearest ocean
its average temperature range is more
than double that of antwerp
[Music]
extreme conditions arise from the
differences in how land and sea absorb
the heat from the sun
in summer land areas heat up much more
quickly than the ocean which can
distribute its heat at depth
whereas in winter the oceans still have
some store of heat left over to create
milder conditions while the land cools
much more quickly
coastal regions reap the benefits of the
ocean
and the continental interiors are left
out in the cold
or the heat
[Music]
and it is not only temperature that
defines continentality
any satellite image of earth today will
reveal that the deep hearts of
continents are often deprived of the
green of life
they are deserts
where little rain falls and living
things struggle to survive
one reason for this is the sheer
distance rain is ultimately derived from
warm oceans and the greater the distance
from those oceans the less rain that is
left to fall
but the clouds and life-giving rain are
also blocked by mountain chains
the warm moist air is forced up steep
mountain slopes where it cools condenses
and rains out
the resulting rain shadow mirrors the
real shadow of the mountain but can
extend much further inland
[Music]
if such extreme conditions are to be
found inside the modest continental land
masses on earth today then we can only
begin to imagine the
supercontinentality that held sway in
the interiors of pangaea
or rodinia
or
[Music]
supercontinents positioned at low
latitudes close to the equator would see
their central regions transformed into
baked dusty deserts where not a drop of
rain would fall for centuries
or even
millennia
[Music]
even for the likes of panoshia
straddling the south pole ice caps would
be slow to grow if the snow that fed
them never arrived
the suturing of crustal fragments during
the assembly of supercontinents also
generated mountains in staggering
abundance
with every continental collision huge
ranges and plateaus to rival the
himalayas and tibet are heaved out of
the tortured ground
monumental towering belts stop weather
in its tracks creating rain shadows that
bring the desert ever closer to the
coasts
with vast mountain ranges creating a
high altitude labyrinth of blockages and
diversions wind and weather is whipped
into a frenzy
high level plateaus pump warmth and
moisture into the upper atmosphere
driving monsoons that sweep their
devastation across the coastal
landscapes
with terrible regularity
[Music]
flash floods and ephemeral rivers from
these violent storms create huge inland
deltas that irrigate the arid lowlands
for a time
but these same winds
now stripped of their moisture
howl across the featureless deserts
sending dust storms tumbling viciously
for thousands of kilometers
[Music]
such harsh conditions in the centers of
most of earth's supercontinents would
have been little concern for life
since living things only began to
colonize the land surfaces of gondwana
and pangaea
but for those pioneering forests insects
and teetering tetrapods
supercontinental life was unforgiving
many places were all but uninhabitable
the dry interior deserts
the wild wind-whipped mountain tops
but towards the coasts and along
sustaining rivers and deltas the
supercontinents offered a bounty of
newly exposed mineral nutrients and all
living things thrived
populations on land boomed and crashed
with the march of the seasons
compared to the constancy of life
beneath the waves
[Music]
but there was plenty of time to adapt
the dance of the continents may seem
frantic when we fast forward through
earth's history
but the reign of pangaea spanned the
entire ancestry of the dinosaurs
from the first slithering steps onto
land in the devonian to the mighty
long-necked lizards
of the jurassic
[Music]
we cannot truly know what it is to live
on a supercontinent
since that is not something humans have
ever experienced even in genetic memory
and unless humankind persists for
another 250 million years or so we may
never know
we are living through a time of
continental dispersion
but another supercontinental age
is on the horizon
even now the assembly is beginning
the current movements of the plates will
bring continents together one by one
africa and arabia will grind northwards
into europe closing the mediterranean
and creating a mountain range in its
place
australia and antarctica will collide at
high latitudes and may soon creep north
together
eventually the atlantic will stop
widening and its crust will begin to be
subducted
[Music]
north and south america will rotate
towards each other as they bear down on
the afro-eurasian amalgamation
and as the north atlantic disappears the
indo-atlantic is
trapped there's a huge inland sea
between south america
india and southeast asia
when the collisions are finally
concluded
250 million years from now
perhaps all of the modern landmass will
be combined into one immense
supercontinent
pangaea
ultima
[Music]
like the generations of supercontinents
before it pangea ultima will be built
from the shattered remains of its
ancestors
but will have a character all of its own
for a biosphere like ours now so
thoroughly wedded to our continental
land
it is hard to say whether such unity
will be a blessing
or a curse
[Music]
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth
don't forget to like and subscribe and
leave a comment to let us know what you
think
thanks for watching
and we'll see you next time
[Music]
you